qui va être
bourré ou quoi
Sophie brown
vous qui voulez acheter vous pouvez pas
débarquer et vous payer un château
burger
l'étiquette c'est votre Grâce
je lui rendre la vie tellement
impossible qu'elle voudra plus voir à
château de toute sa vie
[Musique]
et bien visiblement on est en train
d'écrire
sois qu'on a percé sa carapace
il a un grand cœur
ça fait vraiment longtemps que je t'ai
pas vu sourire comme sa
carrière dépend de l'écriture de ce
roman alors viens chez nous
mon vol décolle demain
envoyez-moi une copie quand vous serez à
New-York n'oubliez pas de me donner
votre adresse
vous avez vraiment l'intention de la
laisser partir
si c'est ce que tu veux
à notre époque
sont les gens qui croient
mais moi il se pourrait que j'y crois